all the money I'm coming back home and I
still gotta work yeah it's gonna be a
pro it's gonna definitely gonna be a
problem and [__] are gonna be
like you know what I'm gonna get me
someone that's actually your partner
when you have a Caribbean mom or that's
most mom I guess they come back home and
one thing they think I'm saying yo yo
you guys are ungrateful you never helped
me I do everything about that's what
they talk about if your mama sees you on
your couch and you're not doing it and
she cooks she cleans it she works and
she brings a bill you don't bring
anything in the house she's gonna feel
like you're not doing anything and
you're not bringing anything in the
house yeah but what percent of women can
fix a car what percent of women do the
yard work like a lot of times women will
keep score but we don't talk about what
the men do it's always about all we do
for them but we a lot of times women
don't even realize how much men do for
us